[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous mercredi 21 février
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
26 minutes pour passer en revue toute
l'actualité locale tout de suite les
titres de cette édition une antenne
relais qui ne passent pas à noisy-le-roi
certains habitants sont opposés à la
construction d'un pylône de 34 mètres
d'un opérateur téléphonique
une bataille juridique s'est enclenchée
avec la commune le dossier a été porté
devant le tribunal administratif de
versailles un budget participatif pour
la troisième année consécutive et les
mises en place à maurepas
cent cinquante mille euros sont alloués
au financement dans un projet a choisi
par les habitants d'où vient ce concept
chronique à suivre dans ce journal
et puis elle profite des vacances
d'hiver pour se refaire une santé la
piscine des clayes sous bois est en
travaux depuis quelques jours deux
semaines de chantier pour la maintenance
refaire les peintures également à
nettoyer les filtres à suivre aussi dans
ce journal deux invités marcia bertrand
président des petits cosmonautes
l'association alimentaire oeuvre pour la
rééducation des personnes handicapées
elle le fait avec une méthode innovante
on en parlera dans un instant et on
parlera également vacances d'hiver dans
ce journal avec emmanuel jean emmanuel
charonnat qui présentera les animations
proposées en ce moment au château de
breteuil à choisel la colère gronde à
noisy-le-roi un conflit oppose depuis un
an des habitants à la municipalité
motifs l'installation prochaine d'un
pylône de 34 mètres par l'opérateur free
ce projet d'antenne relais doit voir le
jour dans une forêt les opposants
mettent en avant plusieurs impacts
néfastes les précisions avec ce sujet de
nicolas landry et michael enzi d'euros
il y aura donc un monstre d'un mètre
vingt de diamètre donc un mètre vingt de
diamètre s'affaissa qui sera positionnée
au milieu avec une hauteur qui sera deux
fois supérieur à la taille des arbres
jean marc et loire est révolté cet
habitant de noisy le roi se bat avec
plusieurs riverains depuis plus d'un an
contre le projet de l'opérateur free sur
la commune et l'arrivée dans cette forêt
d'un pylône de 34 mètres près du
rond-point du centaure il mesure qui
pourrait avoir un impact sur
l'immobilier
ça peut effectivement stopper des ventes
de biens parce que comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer
voilà on a nos maisons qui sont
valorisés à tel montant du mètre carré
et il faut savoir que lorsque on
tournera la tête tous dans nos jeux
depuis le jardin dans un rayon de 500
mètres et qu'on verra ce monstre qui va
dénaturer notre village nous craignons
aussi une perte immobilière autre
argument avancé par les riverains la
couverture réseau de ce pylône ne serait
pas optimale vu l'emplacement du ce
pylône et de sa hauteur il va y avoir un
très gros écran avec la forêt tu es sur
le côté et les maisons environnantes
ce qui fait que le quart de noisy sera
invisible pour contrer le projet les
riverains ont distribué des tracts
organiser des manifestations devant la
mairie une requête en annulation a
également été déposé au tribunal
administratif de versailles en juin 2017
si tous les recours sont rejetés les
habitants pour était allé plus loin
alors si les travaux commencent il faut
savoir qu'il ya une forte mobilisation
citoyenne et il est à craindre
effectivement il y aura certainement des
actions de blocage de chantier vis-à-vis
des engins de chantiers qui pourraient
être opérés par free je le crains nous
on voudrait éviter d'arriver à une telle
extrémité
de son côté la mairie co signataire du
bail ne souhaite pas s'exprimer sur le
sujet pour le moment
un courrier a été envoyé par les élus à
l'opérateur free pour avoir des
précisions sur le dossier à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la ville de
maurepas vient de lancer la troisième
édition de son budget participatif
jusqu'au 12 mars les habitants peuvent
proposer des idées projets qu'il soit et
qu'il souhaite voir se réaliser
bonsoir or et ori les onze la rédaction
de tv 78 d'où vient ce concept de budget
participatif
alors l'idée vient de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique au brésil à porto allègre
c'était en 1989
en france il faut attendre 2014 pour
voir des communes proposé ce concept
elles étaient au nombre de 6 25 en 2016
en 2010 7 46 communes françaises étaient
engagées dans un budget participatif
alors on peut citer paris et rennes et
puis bien sûr norpac est d'ailleurs la
seule commune des yvelines à ce jour à
proposer cela le principe est bien c'est
d'associer les habitants au choix de
dépenses d'investissement qui les
concernent faire également aimé
j' ai des besoins que les élus
n'auraient pas vu non maurepas aurélie
c'est une enveloppe de cent cinquante
mille euros qui a été allouée pour la
réalisation des projets est ce que c'est
un montant commun toutes les villes où
finalement l'enveloppent varie pas ce
que les communes alors justement savary
puisque par exemple pour les grandes
villes comme paris l'enveloppent
consacrée au budget participatif
représente 5% du budget d'investissement
donc en 2017 cela représentait 92
millions d'euros
alors évidemment ce n'est pas comparable
avec les communes de moins de vingt
mille habitants comme par exemple
maurepas puisque c'est environ 2% du
budget alloué aux investissements soit
donc une enveloppe de cent cinquante
mille euros
mais quels sont les projets qu'on pût
être déjà être réalisé à maurepas
le skate park situé au stade du bois
proposé lors de la première édition a
été inauguré en juin 2010 est un
parcours streetwork ott a également été
construit au stade du bois le streetwear
cote 1 c'est une salle de musculation en
plein air et puis au chapitre
environnement dix hôtels à insectes qui
avait été plébiscité lors de la deuxième
édition ont été disposés dans plusieurs
endroits de la ville pour terminer une
question pratique comment font les
habitants de maurepas pour participer à
ce budget participatif
alors c'est tout simple il suffit de se
rendre sur le site de la ville de
maurepas une page dédiée au budget
participatif permet de soumettre son
projet après avoir enseigné vos
coordonnées vous devez d'écrire
l'idée que vous souhaitez voir réaliser
vous pouvez joindre également si vous le
souhaitez une photo un dessin bien un
document et alors là vous avez jusqu'au
12 mars et les services de la ville
ensuite étudieront la faisabilité des
projets jusqu'au 9 avril
les projets retenus seront ensuite
soumis au vote des mauritaniens du 9 au
23 avril
merci aurélie penser à éclairage sur ce
budget participatif et je me tourne vers
l'autre personnes présentes avec nous en
plateau marcia bertrand bonsoir on ça
vous êtes la présidente de l'association
les p'tits cosmonautes une association
qui est basée à à montigny le bretonneux
alors l'association aides à la
rééducation des personnes handicapées
grâce à une méthode novatrice cette
méthode s'appelle terra suite c'est une
thérapie intensive
en quoi consiste-t-elle cette thérapie
base
sur la plasticité cérébrale et sur la
condition physique de l'enfant
on peut seul enfant jusque limites et
pourra pratiquer on utilise une
combinaison spéciale qui apporte une
distillation sensoriel à l'enfant et qui
appartenant à deux gammes en
biomécanique en fait l'enfant est il à
quai à la bonne posture d'accord pour
pouvoir faire les exercices on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler de cette
combinaison
qu'est ce que ça apporte de plus tard la
suite par rapport à d'autres thérapies
existe en fait le grand d'intéresser
qu'elle soit pratiquée d'une façon
intensifs
on propose trois heures par jour pendant
trois semaines c'est là que les études
ont montré qu'ils ont pour avoir plus de
plasticité cérébrale ou bien expliqué qu
est ce que ça c'est la plasticité
cérébrale ce que vous pouvez imaginer là
on a hurlé tempête la neige on a ou une
route barrée
il fallait bien trouver d'autres routes
à côté pour arriver au l'adresse
souhaitée
donc la plasticité cérébrale c'est la
capacité à s'adapter interrompre eux on
peut prendre des déviations d'accord
pour arriver au même but pour arriver
aux mines et aux fouilles à mesure qu'on
est bien entraîné on arrive chaque fois
plus vite plus facilement parce qu'on
commence à identifier les chemins du
coup sûr pratique d'une façon intensive
en fait on ne donne pas l'opportunité au
cvo d'y avoir des mauvaises expériences
quand vous dites entre s'il sait combien
de combien de séances pendant trois
semaines de lundi au vendredi et cetera
pièce s'adresse à toutes les personnes
cap et c'est principalement aux enfants
est-ce que ça s'adresse à tout le monde
applaudit avec les enfants oui mais
c'est une méthode qui est utilisée aussi
avec les adultes avec les problèmes des
avc des accidents et au public après une
chirurgie des choses comme ça on peut
l'utiliser là à 50 ans notre position
c'est avec les enfants handicapés même
parce que moi je m'aime je suis maman
d'un enfant handicapé si la partie de
mon histoire
quand on est parti au brésil autres
enfants à pratiquer la méthode au brésil
si c'est comme ça que vous connaissez
les résultats ont été tout de suite
en fait je suis parti là-bas parce que
les médecins avaient dit qu'il y aurait
en esko lloze dit cela je ne pouvais pas
m'échapper
ils étaient mes plaisirs il y aurait une
scoliose
il était déjà penché en avant et du coup
on en a trouvé cette possibilité on s'y
est lancé
au brésil c'est très répondre les 7e
rapide et gratuite oui oui parce qu'ils
ont des formes très facilement en
amérique elle à l'origine c'est en
amérique au brésil une trentaine de 10
centres qui la pratiquent
ici on n'aura pas s'il y en a un en
espagne en italie en pologne lors de
tous les fans du jeu se déplace en fait
à l'étranger pour le faire oui ok nous
on était déplacée aussi est content on a
pratiqué avec mon fils on a rentré en
france avec un enfant redresser et
jusqu'aujourd'hui le may 6 ans et les
jamais ou disques luz
non c'est ça vraiment
mon envie toutes ces années là des
pratiques pour ce que vous avez créé
cette association l'expérience et j'ai
plein que les familles l'équipe à
pratiquer aussi à l'étranger ils le
savent
vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
combinaison que portent ses enfants pour
faire ses exercices réalisés ces
exercices une thérapie qui en fait
inspiré d'ailleurs c'est oms a fait
référence aussi au nom de l'association
s'est inspiré de la méthode qu'utilise
les cosmonautes quand ils reviennent de
l'espace ils ont ils ont des pertes
musculaire on l'est on il ya une méthode
utilisée pour redonner cet apport de mus
adopté de la wii c'est il y avait eu une
couple de kenickie travailler avec les
astronautes
ils ont créé une combinaison pour
compenser leur perte musculaire lors de
leur séjour doit dès à ses yeux en
espace voilà et les distances afin
qu'elles ont eu un enfant avec paralysie
cérébrale
ils ont adapté cette combinaison là pour
leurs enfants et c'est à partir de là
qu'est née la méthode de leur enfant et
elle a aujourd'hui presque 30 ans 25 ans
et elle a conduit même voiture
aujourd'hui l'accord des progrès
notables
bien sûr qui s'est toujours de travail
propose un travail intensif
il faut dans la rééducation motrice
c'est toujours de travail est allé
composé de koala la combinaison juste on
a pu en voir quelques images à l'écran
s'est cette fois offert est encore une
autre démonstration
en fait c'est un gilet en short en jean
ou genou aussi en mettre une prothèse
mobile quoi c'est aussi une chaussure et
les chapeaux il est ou dont une série
d'élastiques qui sont mises entre les
pièces entre le chapeau et la chemise de
la chemise le chat parce que tous et
toutes ces élastiques ils sont tous les
sens
[Musique]
organiser ces longs à l'efb russe khl de
corps est donc cette combinaison vous
l'utilisez notamment dans vos locaux a
continué le breton
1 place charles de gaulle sous la gare
ouais vous êtes situé tout proche de la
gare de montigny ont retenu la garde
saint quentin en yvelines vous avez des
professionnels aussi qui travaillent
avec vous qui sont spécialisés dans ces
trafics
je suis assez rapide être informés
directement avec la la propriété de la
méthode
isabelle où il était formé avec la
propriétaire de la méthode femme n'a
tout ce qu'il faut non un matériau aussi
bien tout directement de la ba d'accord
et donc le matériel original vous êtes
les seuls en france à pratiquer cette
heure j'ai connaissance oui qu'est ce
que vous espérez maintenant aujourd'hui
quels sont les objectifs les pour votre
association on espère bien qui est qui
les femmes ils viennent nous voir c'est
possible des plans de rendez vous est dû
faire une évaluation gratuite ou voit
bien les objectifs de la famille c'est
qu'ils attendent pour leur enfant et
qu'est ce qu'on peut proposer puisque
c'est en fin de compte c'est
personnalisés
oui c'est un individu nc chacun ses
besoins est ce que tous les enfants sont
réceptifs à cette thérapie où il y en
ait une qui n'adhèrent pas finalement on
essaye toujours les côté ludique des
choses ont fait en fait dit qu'avec les
yeux avec la musique parce que c'est
fatigant on a dans la salle de théâtre
suite
on annonça les jeunes aux hellènes qui
c'est une salle de stimulation
sensorielle aussi ça on peut parler un
autre jour mais si en salles qui
proposent de la relaxation d'accord
après le fort leur comble réconfort dit
en tout cas plus d'informations il ya un
site internet 1 qui existe pour les
petit cosmonaute qui va peut-être
s'affiche en bas d'écran ça y est il
s'affiche vous pouvez retrouver toutes
les informations sur cette méthode merci
marcia bertrand d'avoir est avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes la présidente de
cette association les p'tits cosmonaute
et l'association
je rappelle qu'elles oeuvrent pour la
rééducation des personnes handicapées
grâce à à une méthode innovante qui
s'appelle terrasse 8 une parenthèse
économique maintenant dans ce journal
avec un focus sur une jeune start-up
yvelinoise au printemps prochain et
lancera sa propre marque de lunettes
prémontées qui se veulent design et aux
prix abordables le produit sera vendu
dans des pharmacies mais aussi à chez
les opticiens à zoom réalisé par au
rayon réunion hebdomadaire pour l'équipe
de vie de vue bien vu à quelques
semaines du lancement de cette nouvelle
marque de lunettes versaillaise l'heure
est aux derniers ajustements pour cette
jeune start up imaginé il ya un peu plus
de deux ans cette gamme de lunettes
prémontées propose notamment des verts
multivision en fait en haut du verre
vous allez avoir un verre qui va être
ici sans correction est en bas du verre
vous allez avoir un verre comme sur des
prêts montée avec une correction de plus
une plus ce qui permet d'utiliser ce n'
est tout le temps pour voir aussi bien
de loin que de près l'équipe composée en
partie d'opticiens a misé sur des
matériaux naturels
les lunettes sont composées
majoritairement de coton un matériau
durable dans le temps c'est ce qui a
notamment séduit les designers c'était
quelque chose qui nous intéressait aussi
énormément dans ce projet c'est d'être
sur quelque chose de qualitatif est
aussi un matériau qui est beaucoup plus
intéressant que de faire
l'énième pré montées en plastique
injecté c'est important pour nous d'être
sur ce matériau qui est un très beau
matériaux et on n'utilise pas assez on a
constaté que le secteur de l'optique
aujourd'hui est un secteur en pleine
mutation
on a des nouvelles normes législatives
avec la loi amont des remboursements au
niveau des mutuelles qui diminue on sait
que le pouvoir d'achat au niveau des
français aujourd'hui est faible et les
coûts optiques sont assez élevés donc
l'idée c'est vraiment de proposer ce
produit qualitatif un prix à moins de 40
euros pour justement répondre à un vrai
besoin au niveau de la population
en plus des verts multivision vie du
bien vu propose également des verts qui
protègent de la lumière bleue renvoyé
par certains appareils numériques 18
modèles seront disponibles au printemps
prochain sur un site internet dédié mais
aussi chez des opticiens et des
pharmacies partenaires dans les yvelines
et à paris on ouvre une page vacances
d'hiver dans ce journal elle profite des
congés justement pour s'offrir un
rafraîchissement la piscine salvador
allende des clayes sous bois est fermé
depuis le 16 février pour travaux
peinture maintenance et nettoyage des
filtres quinze jours deux chantiers sont
lancés par saint quentin en yvelines
sujet de camille lambert et contre le
frère des bassins totalement vide
une image peu commune de cette piscine
habituellement très fréquenté par les
habitants des clayes sous bois
pendant les vacances les enfants ne
pourront en profiter la piscine s'offre
son rafraîchissement annuel ya
obligation de vidanger complètement les
hauts-bassins d'une piscine au moins une
fois par an et on en profite puisque
c'est un équipement qui ouvert le plus
possible tout au long de l'année pour
effectuer quelques travaux d'entretien
ce soit de peinture dans l'emplacement
d'éclairage de luminaires de choses
comme ça
entretien des bassins contrôler
nettoyage des filtres à diatomées qui
traitent l'eau mais aussi peinture dans
le hall d'accueil
quinze personnes sont mobilisées pour
ces travaux autant de réaménagement
indispensable pour cette structure des
années 70 c'est une tâche extrêmement
importante et filtres à diatomées c'est
à dire que celle par là où passent
chaque litre de piscine ou dassin tout
ce qui touche à la sécurité de l'hygiène
dans une piscine qui est extrêmement
cadré extrêmement surveillée puisque
deux fois par jour on analyse l'eau pour
vérifier les taux de chloramines les
pollutions éventuelles de l'eau donc il
faut que les installations techniques
puissent fonctionner tous les jours coût
total cinquante mille euros pour la
maintenance et l'entretien
après deux semaines de remise en beauté
la piscine rouvrira ses portes le 5 mars
le cirque du soleil on est revenue à
l'antenne le cirque du soleil qui a
débarqué à parly 2 jusqu'au 24 février
des animations sont proposées au centre
commercial du chesnay au programme des
ateliers pour apprendre à maîtriser les
arts du cirque et à des cession de
maquillage pour les visiteurs en
parallèle et des artistes réalisent des
figures et des jongleries dans les
allées commercial ce mercredi plusieurs
dizaines de spectateurs ont pu suivre le
spectacle réaction collectées au micro
de mickaël millero c'est très
intéressant pour les enfants ça les
occupe north ensemble commercial
c'est poétique c'est varié c'est très
sympathique qui fait une excellente idée
puis ça permet justement de en période
de vacances de les amener à cet art du
cirque qui quand même un art majeur
malheureusement trop peu à peu oublié
aujourd'hui on va dire ça permet de
faire connaître
le siècle aux personnes qu'on va
forcément le temps
occasion d'y aller poussée à la fois
joli c'est un même temps plein de bonne
humeur
et puis son dos et centraide a une autre
idée de sortie pendant les vacances
d'hiver le château de breteuil vous
accueille tous les jours à choisel au
coeur de la vallée de chevreuse bonsoir
jean emmanuel charonnat êtes
l'administrateur du château de breteuil
cousin du propriétaire actuel le marquis
henri-françois de breteuil
alors comme pour chaque vacances le
château propose plusieurs animations on
va en parler dans un instant au château
de breteuil c'est bien sûr une histoire
la famille breteuil en est propriétaire
depuis le xviiie siècle 10,712 est une
famille qui est le dont le destin est
largement lié à celui de l'histoire de
france beaucoup de personnages de la
famille breteuil ont marqué l'histoire
de france tout à fait la famille a donné
trois ministres au bourbon l'insolent
louis xiv où tout lui 15 et le plus
célèbre sous louis saez le ministre de
louis xiv a eu comme bras droit charles
perrault au ministère des finances
et on rend hommage à cette collaboration
de travail et cette amitié entre les
deux hommes avec toutes les scènes des
contes de perrault que l'on peut voir
dans le parc mais breteuil c'est avant
tout un château de famille oui qui est
effectivement dans la même famille
depuis sa construction d'un château qui
n'a jamais été vendu et toute l'histoire
du château est complètement lié à
l'histoire de la famille et la visite
que l'on propose c'est justement un
voyage ludique dans l'histoire de france
à travers l'histoire d'une famille qui a
servi les rois de france
il y à 50 personnages du musée grévin
d'accord qui rendent ce parcours
historique très ludique qui les
personnages de sierre enlevé personnage
de cire dans toutes les pièces du
château costumes et bien sûr dans un
mobilier d'époque le château est
entièrement meublé est très belle
collection d'objets d'art et de tableaux
d'accord le château est toujours habité
par la famille ça le rend vraiment
vivant et cette visite passionne les
petits et les grands
donc c'est incontournable puisqu'il ya
saml tout de l'histoire le compte aussi
vous l'avez dit ça mais plusieurs
plusieurs aspects sa visite
tout à fait il ya la visite avec
vraiment la partie historique qui donne
envie aux enfants des mais l'histoire de
france est aussi intéressé qui fait
réviser leur histoire de france aussi
aux parents et aux grands parents
et puis dans les dépendances du château
il y à toutes les scènes de compte on en
a huit au total dont six qui sont en son
et lumière
et ça c'est vraiment une promenade
féerique dans le monde de l'imaginaire
le monde de perrault vous pouvez
retrouver le petit chaperon rouge le
petit poucet peau d'âne barbe-bleue la
belle au bois dormant et bien sûr
cendrillon il y en a huit au total
donc ça c'est ce qui est aussi au
programme de ces vacances d'hiver il ya
bien sûr aussi tous les jours des
visites guidées du château
les visites guidées tous les jours il y
en a pendant les vacances scolaires il y
en a une
le matin à 11h30 et puis ensuite tout
l'après midi tous les jours également à
16h30 la conteuse emmène les enfants
avec leurs familles dans l'orangerie qui
est chauffée pour raconter pendant une
heure trois histoires de charles
perrault
ça change un peu tous les jours d'accord
et sont les vraies histoires de perrault
pas du tout les histoires que l'on
connaît et walt disney il ya quelques
nuances là vous avez vraiment la ville
et de la version d'origine ou pas les
réadaptation les adaptations dépression
ça permet d'avoir quelques bonnes
surprises d'ailleurs voilà et sur les
huit scènes de compte vous en reparler
qu'est-ce qu'on peut y découvrir
notamment des célèbres on pense à la
belle au bois dormant et reibel our man
au genre dans le château qui va être
réveillé par l'arrivée du prince
charmant
et justement je vous disais les nuances
avec perreault il n'y a pas de baiser
dans le conte de perrault
oui le fait que la princesse se réveille
c'est tout simplement parce que le
prince arrive dans sa chambre au bout
des centres années écoulées
ce sont les deux faits qui font que la
princesse se réveille walt disney a
ajouté l'histoire d'un baiser mais ça
c'est tout à fait venue après alors au
delà de ce parcours du compte de ces
visites guidées y aussi les ateliers de
sophie et les ateliers de sophie prenant
les vacances scolaires et bien tous les
après midi sophie propose aux enfants de
confectionner des masques
puisqu'on est en période de carnaval des
petits tel pour mettre dans le dos des
caps
les costumes divers et variés avec des
paillettes des plumes
voilà c'était un atelier de travaux
manuels qui peut durer tout l'après midi
si les enfants veulent y rester tout
l'après midi ou 20 minutes s'ils veulent
rester 20 minutes c'est au choix des
enfants des parents bien sûr il ya le
salon tu es aussi compter avec de très
bonnes crêpes salon est ouvert de 15h à
18h30 pour le goûter
essentiellement du chocolat chaud les
enfants les parents les grands parents
tout le monde a de quoi se présente
journée sur le sur le château sur le
dimanche parce qu'il fait beau mais
froid et tout ce qui est à voir dans le
parc donne faim donc c'est bien de
pouvoir rentrer dans un salon de thé se
réchauffaient devant un feu de cheminée
et autour de bonnes crêpes dernière
question toutes ces animations elles se
font sur réservation on peut venir
directement sur place devait venir
directement vous pouvez également
prendre vos billets à l'avant si vous
voulez être sûr de ne pas faire la queue
mais il n'y a pas trop de queue en ce
moment d'accord sur notre site
www.breetanner.com faire vous avez un
accès pour une billetterie en ligne si
vous le souhaitez et le sacre internet
sur notre site vous avez surtout toutes
les explications les horaires tout ce
que je viens de vous dire et rappeler
réexpliqué sur le site du site internet
qui s'affiche actuellement pour nos
téléspectateurs merci à jean emmanuel à
chârost d'avoir été avec nous merci à
vous je rappelle l'administrateur du
château de breteuil à choisel au coeur
de la vallée de chevreuse
on parlait du compte justement avec vous
et bien pour refermer ce journal on part
à la rencontre d'une plaisir aux a's qui
met en images et des récits pour enfants
carole guénard est illustrative et luce
illustratrice on va y arriver dans
l'édition jeunesse particulièrement
inspiré par sa ville son univers
gravitent autour du monde végétal elle
expose actuellement la bibliothèque du
château de plaisir et découverte avec
mélanie poker et camille lambert
un jour peut-être croiserez-vous team un
petit crapaud caché dans le parc du
château de plaisir il est le héros d'un
ouvrage d'une illustratrice plaisir
oiseaux les espèces qu'on voit dans
l'album se retrouve dans le parc quand
je les ai rencontrés qu'il faut être
assez discret mais c'est possible on
peut on peut rencontrer tout c'est
toutes ces bestioles et donc c'est en
entendant un son
en été lalita coucheurs qu'un champ
assez particulier me suis demandé ce que
c'était
et quand j'ai découvert que c'était le
mal qui s'occupait des oeufs je me suis
dit 'il est très moderne ce crapaud il
faudrait faire une histoire autour de
lui un ouvrage dont les illustrations
s'expose aujourd'hui au château
carole bénard travail à la gouache un
coup de pinceau délicat donnant une
impression pastel d'une nature à
préserver
c'est un mais
sujet de prédilection à
voilà les petits détails comprend pas
forcément le temps de voir des petites
espèces un peu inconnu qu'on a envie de
deux maîtres de mettre en avant avec
dans l'idée quand même de protection de
protection de l'environnement de
découverte de quelque chose qui est
toujours toujours renouvelé
et pour les artistes est toujours une
source d'inspiration les formes les
couleurs c'est en fini en tête
avec une vingtaine de dessins tout en
finesse carole xena romaine le public
dans un monde enfantin où même les
adultes aimerait se cacher
et pour encore plus de culture ne
manquez pas ce soir le nouveau numéro du
7-8 culture présentée par mélanie poquet
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
l'édition est à revoir comme d'habitude
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 très belle
soirée à tous
[Musique]